what's going on this is ludacris
reporting live from the soul headphones
sweet and you are checking out wired
right well it would be interesting if
it's a headphone war I'm just telling
you that if you want the best quality
sound and the best possible fashion
since style and you need to get so
everyone that's okay we're gonna
eliminate all the confusion we're gonna
tell you which ones to buy are these for
sure by fallout musics my passion so
these headline performs with the bastard
it look the best and they sound the best
this is the best quality sound that you
can ever get in ahead of all period it's
another level of detail we got the best
engineers from around the world that's
quality sound he's had fun going to be
the best a sound the best there's not a
bit of sign of hair come to the world
I'm just telling you the quality for the
price these headphones be the best
period and I say that with the utmost
confidence the way they look man
survived color coordination you're
actually gonna look a lot cooler windy